I wish to introduce Robert
[Music]
Spencer you you know him as the Director
of jihad watch uh the program of the
David Howard's Freedom Center uh my
colleague my Duo of the dynamic duo uh
author of 15 books he's LED seminars on
Islam and Jihad for the FBI uh listen no
one has his bio his impressively
scholarly you know you know brilliant
Wordsmith that he is but I want to say
something because I've worked with
Spencer now since
2008 and what you don't know about Mr
Spencer is there is no braver
man whatever plot I ever came up with
whatever ad whatever conference he never
said you know this could be trouble
he has joined with me and I will tell
you he's exceptional and brave
because so many people have fallen away
because I won't trim I won't trim we got
so many trimmers that the garden is
perfect he won't trim he never sherks he
never shrugs he's the bravest man I know
ladies and gentlemen Robert Spencer
[Music]
thank you very much it's uh so wonderful
to be here I wanted to ask you you know
history generally calls various periods
of time the Gilded Age the gay 90s the
roaring I think that this age that we
live in now is the age of
absurdity the other day there was a
Muslim in France screaming lahu Akbar
and he stabbed a rabbi and the French
Authority said he has psychological
problems it has nothing to do with
terrorism the other day in Montreal a
woman in a car a Muslim woman driving a
car ran over two police officers while
screaming Allah abbar and the Montreal
police assured us it had nothing to do
with
terrorism and so this is an absurd age
we know obviously that there is a war
the Islamic state has declared war on
the United States that's Isis or isil as
the president calls them we know that
Iran has been on a war footing with the
United States since
1979 and every time somebody screams
Akbar and kills somebody or blows
something up authorities assure us it
has nothing to do with Islam and that
Islam is peaceful and benign and that
these people are mentally ill and that
they are isolated discreet criminal acts
instead of what they should be regarded
as battles in a war and now we know
actually because of some recent
Revelations why we live in this absurd
age where obvious reality is so brazenly
denied by everyone in the political and
media Elite and we know that for one
primary reason this is happening that
they're being paid we know now that
George Soros funded a massive campaign
and his organizations paid millions of
dollars to mainstream media sources to
get favorable coverage of the Iran
nuclear deal do you think that that was
the first time that the media has been
paid I doubt it think about some other
things we know that Omar matin shot
killed 49 people and wounded 53 others
in the gay nightclub in Florida and
right after that
happened there were all sorts of stories
about how no no no this has nothing to
do with Islam despite all his statements
about Isis and all the rest of it the
usual things that are ha that that that
are going along with an attack like that
screams of aak bar and everything else
nothing to do with Islam it turns out
that he was gay and he was angry because
somebody had infected him with HIV and
so he went and shot up the nightclub and
we heard this right did you hear that
and we heard this from multiple
mainstream media sources that this had
nothing to do with Islam and he was
having gay Liaisons he had gay apps on
his phone and then his lover showed up
heavily disguised on CNN I think it was
maybe MSNBC what's the difference and
saying that uh this had nothing to do
with Islam and that this guy was just
angry about his gay
relationships and
then on page 37 of the times if that
buried in the news Cy
was the fact that the FBI actually found
no gay apps on his phone and no evidence
that he had any gay relationships at all
and then you wonder who who who put that
guy up heavily disguised why was he
heavily disguised he wasn't under any
threat where did this disinformation
campaign come
from and it's the same answer that
people are being paid to do this and
it's very clear now
the Iran nuclear deal was put over on
the American people by the Obama
Administration that knowingly lied and
then Ben rh's Obama's foreign policy a
boasts about lying about it and it comes
out then that the media was paid to
cover it in this
way now today is August 22nd 2016 on
August 22nd 2015 no it's the 21st sorry
I'm I'm I'm Forward Thinking and a year
ago today I would not have been been
nearly as optimistic speaking to you as
I am today and that is because in the
first
place it is starting to come out what's
happening I couldn't have told you that
the media was paid last year now it's
been established and documented and so
we know that there is a massive
globalist campaign to destroy nation
states and Destroy nationalism and
essentially make every place pretty much
like every other place in the utopian
hope that that will mean that there be
no more war and no more conflicts
because why
bother and that that campaign is being
funded by moneyed interests in other
words it's starting to come out now it's
been
exposed a year ago we could think these
things and then it would be dismissed as
some crazy conspiracy theory now it's
documented a year ago the hegemony of
these political and media Elites was
essentially
unchallenged now there have been two
massive challenges to them and that is
why we should have every reason to Hope
at this point despite how Bleak things
are and they
are the first one was the brexit
vote the brexit
vote the brexit vote was against all
expectations right if you remember the
polls all told us it's going to lose
Nigel farage in Britain who was Champion
championing the the the brexit vote the
vote to leave he actually conceded
defeat not once not twice but three
times he said well looks like they won
and then he had to eat his words and
claim
victory age of
absurdity and nobody expected that
Britain was going to vote to get out but
people were fed up they were not fed up
in a way that they're going to tell a
holster because they know the social
appropri that will come upon them if
they say yes yes I'm a racist bigoted
islamophobe and I want out of the
European Union that is pushing this
Muslim migrant Invasion on us but people
did vote that
way and whether or
not whether or not Britain actually
leaves the European the European Union
because that's still a qu open question
especially with Teresa may who invites
in every Jihadi on the planet into
Britain right now there are two
Pakistani imams
who in Pakistan they have a blasphemy
law you know death penalty for blasphemy
there was a courageous politician a few
years back who was campaigning for the
repeal of the death penalty for
blasphemy blasphemy Salon uh t uh never
mind you can look up his name
anyway he was murdered by a Muslim who
was in favor of the blasphemy law and
then became a hero in Pakistan these
imams praised the
killer glorified him as a warrior for
Allah and they were led into Britain no
problem they're on a tour of mosqu
speaking tour in mosques right
now Teresa may the prime minister of
Britain admitted them and banned us for
opposing Jihad I was actually banned the
letter from the home office Banning me
from Britain said that you said that
Islam has a doctrine of warfare against
unbelievers and so you can't come
in now obviously that's obviously true
and she let in these two guys and there
are hundreds of other jihadis that she's
LED in all the time and they obviously
believe that Islam has a doctrine of
warfare against unbelievers the
difference between them and me is that
they're for
it you can't be against it and get into
Britain
nowadays but the thing is so I don't
know that they're actually going to
leave with a prime minister like that
but the the point has been made
nonetheless the 52% who voted to leave
they're not going to go away and they're
not going to give up
and the power of the elites is
cracking that's what that vote tells us
the second big sign of the weakening of
the elite strangle hold on the public
discourse and on public policy is the
candidacy in the success of
[Music]
trump because Trump threatens them like
nobody has threatened them since Ronald
Reagan
and he shows up the Deep frustration of
the American people that we're tired of
being lied to we're tired of being
deceived we're tired of being
condescended to by these people who
presume to tell us not to believe the
evidence of our own senses but to
believe no no no this guy screaming
abbar and waving a quan around while
he's beheading somebody has nothing to
do with
Islam and Donald Trump has said more he
hasn't said everything right but he has
said more about the Jihad threat than
any candidate since John Quincy
Adams and since I'm afraid Adams is not
available to run this
year that narrows our choices but
whatever happens with Trump the fact is
that the things that the media has given
him the most trouble about are the
things that make him the most popular
build the wall Muslim ban on immigration
these are the things that people are F
saying finally we have a politician
who's actually addressing our concerns
instead of doing these things that are
committing essentially National and
civilizational suicide and telling us
it's good for
us and so whatever happens whether he
wins or loses these people who have
brought him to the point where he is now
are not going to go away either and the
political and media Elites are are
deeply threatened I don't know that
there's any amount of money George Soros
can pay for mainstream media coverage
that is going to completely destroy and
obliterate the forces that are now
arrayed against the
elites and that is all to the good we
have every reason to believe that as
things continue to get worse they're
going to get better and
better now that's paradoxical but it's
absolutely true because as the situation
continues and as they continue to try to
reassert their power there is going to
be more and more of a push
back and I do believe that uh the motto
of my home state of South Carolina is
appropo here Doom Spiro Sparrow while I
breathe I
hope and as the uh great philosopher
Yogi Bara said it ain't over till it's
over and it ain't over it's a lot less
over than it was a year ago
today and so I thank you for your
presence here encourage you as Pamela
did to fight on in every way possibly
can in your spheres and to take hope
that you know we really have the easy
job because all we have to do is tell
the truth and I don't have a good enough
memory to be a
liar
and the elites they have to keep
blanketing us with this nonsense because
it's so obviously false every time
there's another Jihad attack there 10
stories on CNN and MSNBC and the New
York Times about how Islam is a religion
of peace and they have to keep yelling
at us about that because it's so
obviously ridiculous and so in this age
of absurdity let us not be absurd and
that's all we have to do to win thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
truly two of the most courageous people
I know and who have done more for
Liberty than anyone thank
[Music]
you to these